are we the most blessed people on this  planet or what  there's really nothing like climbing a  mountain and standing on top of it  i just fell in love with going really  fast  that's where life feels the most rich  the most real to me  makes you feel so connected to  everything around you  it is calculated madness  [Music]  so exhilarating and just super dangerous  i like feeling on that edge of  uncertainty  oh i want that feeling again  i don't believe you guys are making the  right decisions  we're down to one full day of food we're  in a really bad spot  we watched  200  avalanches my gosh  i fought like hell to try to get us on  the right path we need to move  i don't think that's the way  one mistake and you're dead  putting it all on the line  is where that feeling of freedom comes  from  no fall zone means no fall or you die  is the pursuit  worth the risk  [Music]  you